small foot had some pretty big names can
you guess the stars behind the voices in
this warner bros animated movie
it doesn't get more stacked than the
voice cast behind this wholesome
animated adventure about a yeti who
discovers the existence of humans
aka smallfoot we'll go over the
star-studded voices behind the lovable
yetis in the movie
you'll never guess who's who from a
former disney channel star to a late
night host to an nba all-star
everyone thinks you're this terrifying
monster that's all
first up is michi welcome to the scs
michi leads the ses the small foot
evidentiary society
which seeks to prove the existence of us
small foots the voice of michi has taken
hollywood by storm with major roles in
spider-man
hbo's euphoria and the greatest showman
where she also sang
there's more to life that meets the eye
of beauty to behold
have you guessed it yet maybe this will
help she got her start on the disney
channel as rocky blue and shake it up
that's right it's the one and only
zendaya zendaya is michi
next up migo migo is the main character
a yeti who discovers a small foot and is
banished because no one believes him
everyone i saw us
the hunky actor who does the voice of
migo isn't known for his voice and was
surprised to find himself singing in
small foot but he's actually got some
good pipes
while he didn't sing before he is known
for his amazing dance moves getting his
start in the movie step up and has since
broken out in major movie franchises
like magic mike and 21 jump street
yep migo is voiced by channing tatum but
the movie isn't all yetis
percy is the british filmmaker who's out
to prove the existence of bigfoot
little does he know he actually finds
him when he runs into migo
blimey good crowd did you put an
amplifier inside there or something
percy even gets to sing his own karaoke
rendition of queen and david bowie's
under pressure which is actually a clue
to this voice actor's identity
percy is voiced by a certain late night
tv host who has a habit of doing karaoke
while carpooling
it's james corden of course host of the
late late show and his famous carpool
karaoke series
corden does a great job as the
adventurous smallfoot who befriends migo
the scs is full of colorful characters
one of which is kolka
we welcome him with all arms sound
familiar
you might recognize her voice as the
voice of carmen sandiego on the netflix
animated series of the same name
but she's also done a range of movies
from rom-coms like someone great to
sci-fi thrillers like annihilation
any guesses well this star got her big
break on jane the virgin
and even won a golden globe for her work
on the show it's jane herself
gina rodriguez she definitely brings a
lovable personality to the role of culka
migo's father dorgal plays an important
role as the village gong ringer
up and at amigo time to ring the gun and
his voice is awfully familiar
this actor's distinctive voice has
graced a number of animated projects
including dr seuss's the lorax disney's
hercules and space jam
but it's dorgel's short stature for a
yeti that might give you an idea of who
the man behind that wicked mustache is
dorgel is voiced by none other than
danny devito this legendary actor has
done
everything from sitcoms like it's always
sunny in philadelphia to countless
iconic movies from batman returns to
matilda
three times to come up four pools means
you've reached the bottom and it's safe
for us to come down
did you know that guangi is voiced by an
nba all-star and he's considered one of
the greatest basketball players of all
time
what's he doing in a warner bros
animated movie you ask well this is one
versatile athlete who's been known to
dabble as an actor when he's not
dribbling on the court
if you guessed lebron james you'd be
correct that you didn't know that lebron
has also done movies and tv
usually he plays a version of himself so
it's great to see him step out of the
box as guangi
let's hope lebron continues to do
awesome voiceover work like this
yetis don't exist next up is brenda
percy's assistant who doubts the
existence of yetis and has a strong
moral backbone
fittingly she's voiced by one of the
time's 30 most influential teens of
2016.
this young actress is known for her
activism and sense of style
but you probably know her from the abc
sitcom blackish where she was so good
that her character got her own spin-off
gronish star yara shahidi is the voice
behind brenda who in turn is the voice
of reason behind percy
you know that annoying sibling who
always butts into everything you're
doing
hey what are you freaks doing out here
well in small foot that's thorpe michi's
dim-witted older brother
got any idea who plays the role with
spot-on comedic timing
well he's a comedian who started out by
hosting his own long-running youtube
series
but he has since made the jump to movies
with roles in 22 jump street and
grown-ups too
this comedian also received praise for
his performance in netflix american
vandal
that distinctive jock voice belongs to
jimmy tatro host of life according to
jimmy
the airplane pilot that migo first meets
is voiced by the son of two famous
hollywood movie stars he's now an actor
himself
having made his film debut in the hunger
games the son of meg ryan and dennis
quaid the pilot is voiced by jack wade
jack actually refused his father's help
when he was just starting out as an
actor so he's gotten here all on his own
that's dedication
you can catch jack wade on the superhero
satire tv series the boys
and in the upcoming scream sequel that's
in the works stonekeever is the wise
village elder who leads the yeti clan
and guards their secrets
i told you the stones were here to
protect us he's also michi's father and
can hold a sick beat
what's true or not true is nbi of the
beholder
if you're wondering how stonekeeper got
so good at rapping it's because this
actor wasn't always an actor
he started out as a rapper and hip-hop
icon in the 1990s
that voice belongs to common who's
anything but common when it comes to
talent
while he still produces music he's also
made a name for himself as an
accomplished actor and voiceover artist
in movies like selma happy feat 2 and
john wick chapter 2.
mama bear shows up in the movie with a
growl giving both migo and percy a
fright while they're holded up in a cave
during a blizzard
my husband is back there sound asleep
but she turns out to be friendlier than
she seems simply protecting her family
the actress who voices mama bear is
known for her sitcom work
especially her leading role on everybody
loves raymond for which she won two
emmys and her work on the middle
this fierce mama is played by patricia
heaton who's no stranger to playing the
part of a strong mother figure
speaking of mama bear did you know that
in the uk release of smallfoot this part
was played by a totally different
actress
that's right they wanted a voice that
brits would recognize and this voice is
definitely a big one
while she plays mama bear she's
typically known as the baby of the group
you might know her as baby spice from
the spice girls this superstar
stepped in to voice the role of mama
bear for uk audiences
it's emma bunton who seems like she had
a blast playing the part
she's a feisty thing who wore the role
of mama bear best
patricia heaton or emma bunton gary is a
minor role but it's played by a guy who
has more than a little experience with
animation and
know how you get voiceover i'll try it
i'm just so scared the panic yeti is
voiced by one of the co-creators of the
super popular cartoon rick and morty
he's also done voice work on adventure
time and gravity falls
voiced by justin roiland gary makes a
big impression with his little screen
time
royland said it only took him about an
hour to record all of his parts in the
movie
and finally rounding out the ses is
fleem this little yeti provides comic
relief and always has something to say
if you die can i have all your worldly
possessions you might not recognize this
actor but he got his start with a minor
role in mean girls
pretty fetch for a first acting job he
also appeared in small roles on a number
of tv shows including good luck charlie
suburgatory atypical and the perry
manson reboot his name is eli henry
fun fact at first henry was only doing
temporary voices for the movie but did
such a great job that he was bumped up
to the main cast
so those are some of the big names
behind these characters we can't believe
how stacked this cast is
how many of these voices did you
recognize let us know in the comments
and don't forget to hit that subscribe
button for more great videos
thanks for watching small foots
[Music]
you